so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics I'm your interim host
Carl Smallwood yes that's my real name
and today we're talking about John D the
necromancing Navigator of the Elizabeth
and age and this is a video I've been
informed is going out during spooky
season my personal favorite time of the
year but due to the way you have to make
videos I'm recording this in September
so I don't have my Halloween costume yet
which was going to be the Grim Reaper
from Horrible Histories which I will be
wearing um for videos on my own channel
fact feeling with Cal SM you can find
link below but I should mention that as
with all of our videos this one is based
on original script submitted by one of
our handsome and well-endowed writers
this one being Mr Larry holsworth whose
links to socials you can find below
alongside my
own so John D serves as a council to
Queen Mary the first as well as Queen
Elizabeth the he received his personal
guidance from astrology communication
with angels fellow scientists and his
own religious fervor he owned one of the
largest libraries in England he traveled
to the capitals of Europe to deliv
lectures on subjects as diverse as
algebra and zoology quite literally the
entire alphabet he was a fellow with Sir
Walter Raleigh Sir Francis Drake and
many other notables of the Elizabethan
era he was a man with a past that is
exceedingly difficult to separate from
myth and legends an example of this is a
story of what allegedly happened during
the Spanish Armada so John D was a
student of meteorology at a time when
predicting the weather was virtually
impossible he is said to have used this
knowledge to recommend to the English
that they refrain from early attacks as
the Spanish Armada approached England de
predicted heavy storms would beset the
Armada when they did some claim that he
used his powers of the occult another
area of study he enjoyed to bring down a
curse on the unfortunate Spanish dooming
them at Sea the English ships rode out
the storms at anchor and then attacked
the few Spaniards that remained that's a
great story though it's likely false d
was in Europe during the year of the
Armada and he's not knowledge of
meteorology is exaggerated by reputation
of the legend his reputation as a
magician grew following his death and
though he studied Alchemy and Magic he
was not known for casting spells at
least not among the educated of his day
until very late in his lifetime when he
had managed to grow the requisite
Wizard's beard here had a deep
interestes in cryptology the interest
has led many to consider him a spy for
Elizabeth I using his lecture tours and
visits to foreign capitals to collect
intelligence and Reporting it encoded
messages to her majesty he was said to
be then quite literally under Her
Majesty's Secret Service some have even
claimed him to have been the inspiration
for Ian Fleming's James Bond though
evidence to support the aceration is
somewhat thin reports that he signed his
coded messages with the number7 have
been repeated frequently online by
lesser websites and channels but
documented evidence of such a signature
has never been found I guess it kind of
makes sense he was literally you know
Majesty's Secret Service separating
truth and fiction in the life of John D
is difficult though not impossible
Legends and Tall Tales intertwine with
his legitimate study of the occult the
power of numbers and the influence of
the planets and stars on humanity and
the language of angels largely forgotten
today he was a major influence on the
Elizabethan age giving to Prosperity
more other things the term the British
Empire John D's father Roland D was a
mercer a dealer of five fabricks if you
don't know and courtier to England's
King Henry VII as such John's early
youth was spend in the presence of
royalty born in 1527 John's education
began at the age of 8 when he entered
the kelwood Chantry school which still
exists today under the name King Edward
the 6 grammar school John remained at
Chelmsford until 1542 when he enrolled
at St John's College in Cambridge he
achieved a bachelor's degree in early
1546 though some sources say he actually
graduated the preceding year among his
areas of study which were numerous were
greek latin scripture navigation
astronomy mathematics geometry and law
his Scholastic abilities were formidable
and upon the founding of the Trinity
College in 1546 by the aforementioned
Henry VII de became an original fellow
while at Trinity he applied his
knowledge of magic of all things to
create stage effects for stage
Productions this led to his reputation
as I you not a magician which became so
widespread that William Shakespeare
himself may have modeled his character
of Prospero in the Tempest on D many
years later in 1548 D traveled to the
continent to continue his studies and
conduct lectures on subjects as
mentioned as Broad and varied as algebra
cartography and the Greek mathematician
ukp he also collected astronomical
instruments and books on a range of
diverse subjects when he returned to
England in the early 1650s he settled
near London to concentrate on writing
study and acquiring a position in the
Royal Court though he never became a
mercer like his father he did become a
member of the worship for company of
Mercers as an inheritance when his
father passed away in 1655 he cast a
horoscope for Queen Mary the first as
well as Princess Elizabeth the result of
his efforts was a child against him of
conjuring which was later raised to
treason D was arrested and imprisoned
before being tried before the Star
Chamber he was tried for a charge which
carried the sentence of execution but he
somehow managed to achieve an acquittal
talking his way out of it not liking the
idea of letting him completely off the
hook the Star Chamber handed the off to
the bishop of London Edward Bonner to
examine him for heresy he managed to
talk himself out of that one too and he
and Bonner became close friends and
allies in court following his acquittals
de approached Mary with the idea of
creating a national library which would
be tasked with the acquisition and
maintenance of books Maps charts records
manuscripts and artifacts for the
support of Education although Mary did
not Charter such an establishment D
began to collect such materials on his
own he kept a library at his home in
Mort Lake just outside London a library
that became the largest in England for
the
time while Queen Mary's supporters were
evidently non- too pleased with these
astrological abilities princess
Elizabeth's were when Elizabeth
ascendant of her throne in 1558 D was
approached by her closest advisers to
use astrological data to select the best
date for a coronation D selected after
again casting the Queen's horoscope the
date of January 15th
1559 D then served in Elizabeth's Court
as her Chief scientific and astrological
adviser a strange combination to Modern
Eyes although Geographic expansion would
seem to be outside of those disciplines
of thought de became an early proponent
of the establishment of British colonies
in the new world as well as a fleet to
protect them he supported Voyages of
exploration and indeed Discovery through
his work in improving navigation
cartography and astronomy he prepared
charts and Maps Acquired and supplied
navigational instruments and instructor
sea farers in their use D worked quite
closely with Francis Drake Martin
frobisher and other British captains of
exploration and Discovery instructing
them in navigation and cartography as
well as astronomy how to read the stars
and travel so you don't just end up at
the asand of Jonah grz when you set sale
De exhibited an early and deep interest
in the possibility of a Northwest
Passage on the continent of North
America which provide a quicker safer
passage to the lands of Asia he also
advocated the creation of permanent
colonies and in the process created the
term the British Empire the queen
supported his ideas and the English
voyages to the new world increased
though it would be many years before a
permanent settlement was ever
established in North America while
serving as an adviser to the queen de
greatly expanded his library at Mo Lake
eventually acquiring more books and
manuscripts than any other library in
all of Britain he graciously made his
Library available to Scholars freely and
even held conferences and seminars with
visitors from across Britain and the
continent while serving as Elizabeth's
Chief astrologer he also devoted a great
deal of his time and attention to
numerology it was his belief that
numbers and Mathematics held the keys to
communicating with the creative forces
of the universe in 1564 he published a
treaties entitled Monas hieroglyphica or
the hieroglyphic monad his work provided
a detailed analysis and explanation of a
glyph or symbol of his own invention the
symbol combin Alchemy mysticism
metaphysics and astrology and
represented a key to unlock the hidden
secrets of the universe according to its
creator this symbol was the monad
declaimed among other things that
meditation on the monad would offer
insights including greater knowledge of
alchemy and the secrets of transmuting
metals to Gold his glyph was eventually
adopted by the word I'm going to
struggle to pronounce the ruian The Rosy
crucians in the 17th century spiritual
movement that first appeared in the
German provinces he also traveled to the
new world courtesy of the Puritans under
John Winthrop Jr one of the founders of
the English New World colony of
Connecticut in admittedly more practical
vein Whiley Elizabeth Services depr
proposed that her government adopt the
Gregorian calendar that effort was sadly
and frustratingly in vain due to the
Protestant reluctance to adopt an idea
proposed by a Catholic though several of
Elizabeth's advisor agreed with de's
suggestion her reluctance to offend her
Protestant supporters with what would
have been a pretty radical change doomed
the idea there was also sufficient
difficulty for establishing colonies in
North America due to problems mostly of
limited financial support only one
failed Colony The Lost Colony of Rowan o
was established in de's lifetime and I'm
sure we've done a video on that we must
have done a video on that at some point
and it'll be linked on screen it's a
fascinating story that has undergone
many many embellishments over the years
I won't spoil it but yeah click that
video after finishing watching this one
by the mid 1570s Deb believed his
influence and standing in the Royal
Court had waned somewhat and several of
his most cherished projects a reform
calendar building an empire in North
America and the search for a North
passage had failed to gain Her Majesty's
approval many of his political opponents
believed him to be a sorcerer and
conjurer and a powerful one at that in a
time when witchcraft was greatly feared
as well as a capital crime he began to
delve more deeply into the occult hoping
to find within the secrets of science
that had not yet been revealed to
him John D is often described as having
possessed the ability to communicate
with angels and beings beyond our
understanding that description is shall
we say inaccurate though he did
transcribe alleged Angelic
Communications given to him by another
to explain in the 1570s D began using a
scriver a crystal ball in order to
contact Spirits From Another World among
the spirits that he attempt to
communicate with were angels as
described in the Bible biblically
accurate Angels those like crazy ass
like twirly monstrosities of eyeballs
and wings he was unsuccessful though
attempts were made through several
experienced scries as well in 1582
Edward Kelly presented himself to D
Kelly sometimes called Edward Talbot had
a somewhat bizarre appearance the result
of a somewhat Checker past his ears for
example were cropped cropping earos with
a common penalty for several crimes in
Elizabethan England among them forgery
and counterfeiting coins Kelly claimed
to be an alchemist and scriver who had
successfully contacted angels in the
past he supposedly demonstrated this
skill to D that same year D was a smart
dude and a guy comes up displaying the
very obvious like results of attempting
to counterfeit money and they claim to
have discovered an A Lot the secrets of
alchemy transmuting base Metals into
gold and he trusted this man the
following year D Kelly and their
families left England to seek patronage
from various European Nobles Kelly
claimed past support from Emperors
Rudolph's the second in Prague however
Emperor Rudolph was shall we say
unimpressed with their claims and
demonstrations and declined to support
them a similar effort with King Stefan
of Poland yield similar unsurprising
results de and Kelly then traveled acoss
R Central Europe for a couple of years
communicating with angels in their sers
with the angels communicating only with
Kelly who would repeat their messages to
d d then would translate them from an
occult language he called among other
names the language of angels subsequent
Scholars are renamed this to the Antion
language and again you a smart dude
you've got a guy who cannot be trusted
like literally is bearing the marks of
committing a crime that involves
deception and they will only communicate
with you and they cannot demonstr
like any of the skills they claim to
possess what are you doing during their
travels across Europe Kelly and D
frequently Clash regarding their goals
and and put all on the same page D
wanted to derive the secrets of creation
for Fairly Noble purposes his idea was
that the dissemination of that knowledge
would end religious conflict Kelly on
the other hand wanted to concentrate
their joint efforts in alchemy and find
the secrets to transmute base Metals
into gold and it's worth no that D
wasn't adverse to solving the mysteries
of alchemy but he believed that his
Divine Mission took precedent and moving
back to that subject according to de's
own Diaries the language of the Angels
was transmitted to Kelly in stages with
the first delivered on March 26th 1583
Kelly claimed that his Crystal revealed
21 individual letters later sance has
revealed squares of letters 49 by 49
which were duly recorded by the pair the
Angels evidently did not want to go to
the effort of translating these letters
to their English equivalents leaving
that task to their receivers D undertook
this task with a plum translating the
language to a great extent and expressed
his own belief that this revealed
language was the one that was spoken
universally before all the events
described in Genesis 1:1 and in that
chapter if anyone doesn't know God
observed the construction of the Tower
of Babel he States and I quote go to let
us go down and share their confound
their language that they may not
understand one another's speech Genesis
11:7 in 1586 William of Rosenberg a
wealthy Bohemian nobleman offered his
patronage to D and Kelly and they
settled for a time in the town of
traybon in early 1587 they were
commanded to appear before papal Nuno to
answer charges of necromancy or
attempting to communicate with the dead
as he had before with the Star Chamber D
managed to answer the questions without
being further charged Kelly on the other
hand aroused the eye of the Nuno in a
later letter the bishop of San SEO who
served as the Nuno report that he
considered the defenestration for Kelly
a common form of execution in Bohemia at
the time and this is a word that I love
one of my favorite words and it just
means throwing someone out of a window
and as rare as you might might think
that sounds there is like a small City
in Prague where it happened three times
and these events are known quite
fittingly as the first defenestration of
Prague the second defenestration of
Prague and the third defenestration of
Prague I've made a video about it on my
own channel f fiend with K Smallwood and
perhaps Kelly had had enough perhaps the
reaction of the papal Nuno frightened
him to the point he decided to escape de
in his work or perhaps the Angels really
did communicate to him the message he
claimed to receive on May 1587 so Kelly
reported that an angel he called Medi
some sources say the angel was actually
called oral had instructed he and D to
share their wives and all of their
worldly
possessions just going to let that one
sit D being the smart man he was of
course complied with this request and
according to his diary on May 22nd 1587
the deed was done and we don't really
know how both women felt about this
though we do know they fasted and receiv
received communion before the event took
place um though he had compelled with
the Angelic command received through his
partner de also use the event to bring
the sances to an end Kelly left his
service and lived in luxury as a patron
of several Bohemian Nobles and Contin to
claim he possessed the secret of
transmuting Base Metals into gold D on
the other hand returned to England in
1589 I I it's a hustle and I I I guess
you kind of got to respect the one of
like oh I'm not getting Communications
anymore I've got oh wait I've got one
last one they want me to bang your wife
and you to give me half your money
it's like I guess he was just a True
Believer contemporaries including fellow
antiquarian John Aubry described de as a
very handsome man with a Long White
Beard customary for a wizard he
habitually wore long roads with hanging
sleeves creting the image of a
stereotypical Sorcerer of the 16th
century man went for with he was he was
Wizard Maxin in the 16th century what a
legend D is known to have been married
three times the first was in 1565 to one
Katherine conal of whom very little is
known beyond their marriage and actually
died in 1574 they had no children
together um his second marriage on the
other hand took place in 1575 just a
year later and ended with her death the
following year her name is unknown again
she bore him no children his third
marriage on the other hand was alog
together more fruitful and this was to
Jane fromond a lady in waiting in
Elizabeth's Court together they had
either seven or eight children we say
this because N9 months after the liaison
between Jane and Edward Kelly commanded
by the Angels she gave birth to a child
which the D's named Theodore d three of
D's children are known to have survived
him his eldest son Arthur D apprenticed
with his father in alchemy and other
subjects accompanied him on his travels
and eventually practiced as a Consulting
physician he served as such in the court
of SAR Michael I first in Russia and
eventually in the court of Charles the
first of England while in Russia he
translated much of his father's work
into Russia the translations were
eventually stolen by yet another
charlatan and perhaps powerful wizard
The Mad Monk ruting Arthur 2 spent much
of his life in the vain pursuit of
converting base Metals into gold with
about the same level of success achieved
by his wizard
father when John D returned to England
he found his home in Mort Lake in Ruins
his Gardens have been destroyed by
vandals and much of his extensive and
impressive collection of manuscripts
books and navigational equipment was
missing he also found England was shall
we say hostile to him the occult magic
Witchcraft and other practices ass with
him in the Public's mind made him
suspect and just can we just give props
to the people who thought it was a good
idea to rob a Wizard's House I know
alleged wizard but still these were you
know very superstitious times and people
just thought nothing of is Su as well
we're going to rob his house and step on
his flowers meanwhile rumors reached
London that Edward Kelly in the service
of Rudolph II had reached the point in
his alch at work that he could actually
start producing gold in large and vast
amounts Elizabeth wanted Kelly in
England ensuring the result of Kelly's
labors enriched her coffers rather than
Rudolphs she instructed her agents to
invite Kelly to return to England which
may or may not have contributed to his
subsequent arrest and incarceration on
the continent knowing of his past
relationship with Kelly and unaware of
the Riff that had Arisen between the two
men he banged his wife Elizabeth Grant a
de deposition of warden of the Christ
College in Manchester she hoped that D
could help persuade Kelly to return the
position was far enough away from London
to distance her from the scholar and
wizard D assumed his new position in
1695 and he remained in Manchester for
the next 10 years demonstrating little
interest in his duties although he
admittedly did Fair better than Kelly
who in 1597 or 1598 sources aren't
really clear um died after being injured
during escape attempt According to some
sources other sources claim that he was
just executed because he couldn't
produce gold with Kelly's death
Elizabeth had no real further use for D
but he remained in his position as
Warden despite the growing Emy of his
colleagues he gradually rebuilt much of
his personal library and continued his
research in diverse subjects which
included remember being being a cool
wizard Elizabeth died in 1603 succeeded
by James I first who had even less use
for a wizard than Elizabeth did no
longer influentially and c and alienated
by his colleagues at Christ college and
suspected of Witchcraft by many more D
stature in England waned in 1605 a wave
of plagues swept through Manchester
taking with it D's third wife and
several of his children following that
loss he returned to mortle he supported
himself and his daughter Catherine by
slowly selling off his possessions and
valuable manuscripts living in poverty
and infamy he died in 1609 at the age of
81 so yeah you live to 81 big old white
wizard work like what what what a
done John D is remembered chiefly as a
sorcerer a petitioner of the occult and
a necromancer who received communication
from the angels and other Spirits a
legacy that is somewhat unfair and
certainly at the very least incomplete
he likely did not predict the storms
that severely damaged the Spanish Armada
nor did he recommend the English
Captain's remaining ports as the armad
approached another version of that story
was that he was warned of the Armada via
Angelic Communication in 1587 regardless
he was in Bohemia in 1588 the year of
the Armada not in London so even if he
did receive this communication he had no
way of getting it to English forces nor
is there any empirical evidence that he
travel throughout Europe as a spy for
Elizabeth I as he's often asserted his
travels were directed at obtaining
patronage that is to say financial
support for his research and
experimentation in alchemy and Angelic
Communications right he he was too busy
communicating with angels to like you
know think about spying there's also no
document proven to have been signed by D
himself that bears the cryptic signature
007 empirical evidence of him having
been dispatched to foreign courts as an
agent of Queen Elizabeth has also yet to
be found however Scholars do generally
agree that D did serve as an inspiration
for Prospero in Shakespeare's The
Tempest Prospero for those who don't
recall is a sorcerer sufficiently
powerful enough to control spirits and
have them do his bidding which D never
seemed to be able to do despite his like
you know wizardly appearance several
aspects of the life of John D and the
fictional Prospero are in accord yet
Prospero was a pagan while D was a
devout Christian Shakespeare wrote The
Tempest in 1610 1611 several years after
de's death and there's no record of a
two ever meeting during de's lifetime
Shakespeare would certainly been aware
of De and it's possible that they did
meet but if so nobody recorded this
momentous event the time when
Shakespeare met a wizard most of the's
actual contributions to what evolved in
the British Empire are overlooked
because wizard buried underneath the
myths and legends attributed to him one
of them being being the coining of the
term the British Empire itself just two
years after his death his vision of a
permanent British colony in North
America came to fruition the founding
the settlement of Jamestown in Virginia
16007 likewise his contributions to
astronomy mathematics navigation as well
as his skills as a cartographer
contributed greatly to the explorations
in North America as well as in the
Indian Ocean and later in the Pacific
but they are also Overlook because again
wizard he was also clearly a jurist of
considerable skill having successfully
defended himself self before the Star
Chamber a Papal Nuno and before many
foreign Courts at various times who
accused him again of being a wizard
during a period when those suspected of
being a wizard were routinely condemned
and executed maybe he was a wizard or
maybe he just really good at arguing
we'll never know as for story of alchemy
well I guess you can Snicker at that
it's worth noting that at the time and
for centuries afterwards Alchemy was a
legitimate field of like academic
Pursuit that was like you know
undertaken by many notable names
throughout history including Isaac
Newton and K JN the same is true of
angelic communication like d was
following what he genuinely believed to
be a legitimate scientific Pursuit when
he engaged in the process of
communicating with angels and recording
their language Edward Kelly may have
been likewise sincere there were
consents of Scholars is that he was just
a charlatan who wanted to use the more
reputable D to promote his scams and
bang his wife and it's instructed to
remember that D never personally claimed
to have heard angel's voices or
visualized them in the crystals only
Kelly saw the letters presented them to
seers have been gazing into crystal
balls and predicting events ever since
just as they had before D came to the
practice and it's kind of sad that his
reputation as an eminent scientist and
philosopher was already in tatters later
in his life with widely ranging reports
of his sorcery necromancy Conjuring and
practice of other black Arts supplanting
his numerous scientific achievements his
reputation dips so low that de
petitioned King James for protection
against slander and Lial writing to the
king in 16004 and explaining that none
of the and I quote very strange and
frivolous fables are history told of me
are true the king did not respond so I
hope everybody enjoyed this video and is
getting ready for the spooky season I
certainly am and as mentioned at the
start of this video unless it was cut
out because edit is a coward um I will
be wearing a Halloween costume for our
week of spooky content over on fa fiend
as well as Wiki weekends which I run I
don't think actually no don't think I
have time to wear a costume for Wiki
weekends we'll definitely be doing a
week of spooky themed content um also as
mentioned at the start of this video the
scripts that I'm reading from was
written by one holsworth follow them on
socials that you can find below
otherwise if you enjoyed the video leave
a like if you've got something to say
about it leave a comment let us know
your favorite spooky Season movie and or
generic monster mine is it's got to be
the Skellington which is why we have the
skeleton in the background that's bonley
that is a a beloved mascot of my channel
f fiend and he's been in near enough
every video I've recorded for the past 3
years in addition if you have anything
to say about my hosting and presentation
style also let me know in the comments B
be nice to get some feedback as I try to
settle into my role as interim host for
this channel you want to see more videos
like this subscribe and as always
everyone out there have the day you all
deserve
cheers